bottom line of war war is a racket as
General Smedley Butler brilliantly put
it you know he's one of mine war is a
racket war is a racket that's the name
of General Smedley Butler is great book
he's a true American Hero he he's a
whistleblower a Marine Corps general who
told the truth about the real nature of
war there is a another professor here I
want to get your take on what he had to
say his name is David Ray Griffin he
said pretty much all the evidence that
America was attacked by Muslims on 9/11
when subject to critical scrutiny
appears to have been fabricated that's
who is who is David this is an academic
this is a professor amortus you know
someone who also now is coming out
putting his career on the line and
everything to speak to say this to
defend Muslims David Ray Griffin has
written I believe about 15 books on 9/11
he is the greatest scholar on the
subject of 9/11 in any country and he is
the co-founder of the process school of
Christian theology which is the most
advanced and respected school of
Christian theology it's the only one
that secular intellectuals really take
seriously he and John Cobb founded that
school so these guys are the greatest
Christian theologians of our time he's
Christian also now yeah yeah Protestant
he taught at Claremont he's retired now
and he and John Cobb have both been very
outspoken in pointing out that obviously
Muslims didn't do 9/11 obviously all of
this was fabricated this the official
story of 9/11 is a complete joke you
know the 9/11 Commission for example
said that have all of these so-called
hijacker pilots who we know by the way
we're not even on the planes the the
best pilot was a guy named Hani Hanjour
who supposedly flew an amazing stunt
flight into the Pentagon while Hani
Hanjour was such a bad pilot that he
couldn't even be allowed to solo in a
Cessna training aircraft and yet the
official story has him taking over the
controls of a 757 at 30,000 feet over
Ohio turning it around making a beeline
for Washington DC flying over the
Pentagon for no reason if you were me
the hell if you were gonna hit the
Pentagon in that situation you just dive
into it but now he goes over the
Pentagon and then does a corkscrew dive
dropping more than
you know 8,000 feet in two minutes which
is enough to pull g-forces to knock
everybody out on the plane and then let
come straight down to the ground and
then level out along the ground and hit
the newly reinforced and largely empty
part of the Pentagon killing only the
accountants who and Anson Office of
Naval Intelligence guys and the
accountants were I'm hot on the trail of
the 2.3 trillion dollars missing from
the Pentagon and guess what
Rumsfeld announced that 2.3 trillion
dollars was missing from the Pentagon he
announced it the night before on
September 10th 2001 this official story
is insane a guy who can't fly does the
least possible damage to the Pentagon by
taking out the accountants who are
looking for 2.3 trillion dollars seven
times the military but annual military
budget which disappeared seven times the
annual military budget disappeared the
night before 9/11 and as announced by
Rumsfeld I mean this official story is
is is just beyond belief I can't it's
still shocking to me that there's
anybody who even accepts it now people
hearing this for the first time I mean
you get kind of nervous to talk about
this because right away people start to
associate you with being you know they
putting labels on you and now someone
might say well you're just a conspiracy
theorist sure you know making this stuff
up there's an official story there was a
committee you know of intellectual
scientists whoever the case and this is
this is what they confirmed and now
you're comfor are you to come question
this well you know there hasn't really
been any significant group of experts of
any kind who have confirmed this
official story they they're you know
there's there was the nist group that
looked at what happened to these three
skyscrapers and the entire World Trade
Center every building in the World Trade
Center was totaled and destroyed most
notably the three skyscrapers that are
blown up in obvious controlled
demolitions but the other buildings were
blown up too with explosives huge you
know the giant crater took coke just
blew away most of building 3 and
building 5 likewise blown up anyway the
the people tasked with explaining this
officially for the government we're all
on the government's payroll and
they still had a terrible time coming up
with any way to explain that but the
9/11 Commission report which is the
official story of the whole event
doesn't even mention building seven
the most obvious Achilles heel in the
official they don't mention it even
mention it
there's nothing zero what what about
this new study from the University of
Alaska that was I believe it was a three
hundred thousand dollar study what did
they conclude that's led by dr. Halsey
of the University of Alaska and Ali's
why is he hosting a study if there's an
official report what would motivate this
I mean how would how would a University
of Alaska go ahead and get funding to do
a study like this why would they be
doing it I think they might have had to
get some independent funding to do with
as I recall this is an independent study
yeah these are the more than ones that
you can you assume you can trust if it's
independent certainly and that's been
the problems is that the official stuff
has all come from people on the payroll
of the US government yeah dr. Halsey of
the University of Alaska and his
colleagues of course looked at building
seven before they when they were first
conceiving of having to look into this
more closely and said this is ridiculous
I mean this is if you actually talked to
these guys and there are many thousands
of architects and engineers who've
signed on at architects and engineers
for 9/11 truth and if you actually talk
to these people you know they're not as
careful as they are in their written
work and so on they try to be very
professional if you sit down and talk
with them they will just you know tell
you how absurd this official story is
how obvious it is that not just building
seven which is the one that the
untrained eye can see is a controlled
demolition but the towers as well are
being blown up that they these buildings
couldn't possibly just fall down for
random causes as the official story
indicates so what would be the motive of
someone like this coming out from this
university this this is a professor I
know there are thousands of people like
this now yeah if you go to architects
and engineers for 9/11 truth you'll see
more than 2,000 architects and engineers
who've risked their life there well I
don't think they risk their lives but
they're certainly risking their
reputations to tell the truth and
they're doing it out of their hearts
they're doing jihad yeah they're they're
doing the truths you had to yeah most of
them are not Muslims a few are
struggling striving to get what they
leave is the truth to get it out what
did this this study confirm at the end
again
well dr. Halsey study from University
Laska I believe is showing in great
detail why building 7 had to be a
controlled demolition most people don't
know that building 7
it wasn't hit by a plane that's right
and it fell down at 5:20 in the
afternoon see the other the big built
most of the World Trade Center was
destroyed in the bombings around 9:00 in
the morning ninth it's actually closer
to 10:00 in the morning but building
seven just fell down for no apparent
reason at 5:20 in the afternoon after a
countdown to demolition went out over
police radio after the commercial radio
station had actually announced that it
was going to be taken down a crowd
gathered around building seven to watch
it come down and then a police pushed
people back forced them away from the
building saying that building is about
to come down you can see the videos of
this and then a police radio countdown
went out ten nine eight seven six five
four three two one and at zero the
building just goes straight down into
the earth as if it were sort of an
elevator going into the earth a classic
controlled demolition what's that top
European demolition expert yeah danny
jowenko a lawyer humm who was the top
expert in Europe on demolitions and he
was shown building seven by a Dutch
media company or of some some
journalists and they he looked at this
and he said well this is obviously a
controlled demolition this is one of the
greatest controlled demolitions I've
ever seen
very professional perfectly done and
they said you know this happened on 9/11
and he said oh really yeah he was
shocked
well I forget how long thereafter maybe
I think it was months or a year or
something after that he died in a very
strange car crash so there's also the
top demolition expert in the UK who has
stated the same thing but off the record
to Alan Hart the former lead BBC
correspondent for the Middle East and he
Alan Hart came on my radio show almost
10 years ago to break the news that the
top British demolition expert also said
that these were
demolitions and Alan Hart himself said
that of course 9/11 was a coup d'etat
and Alan believed that the Israelis were
behind it is it true that there's a new
poll that shows that more and more and
more Americans are questioning the
official story and they're also wanting
a new investigation well the polls have
been all over the map but if you add up
all the polls that have been done since
it happened by about 2006 the country
was split with about a third of the
people not believing the if it you know
really siding with the 9/11 truthers
about a third of the people strongly
identified with the official story and
about a third of the people are sort of
in the middle yeah once one poll
actually showed that it was I think 80
it was 82 percent think that the
government is not telling the full truth
so it's pretty much it's not like
because someone who's a conspiracy
theorist he's putting up a plan saying
okay this is how it happened this is
what they did these are just people who
are just saying it doesn't make sense
it's not logical what's going on like
building seven didn't get hit by a plane
and now just people are coming out
experts you know scientists engineers
former presidential candidates people
law people like Paul what Congress was a
Senator Paul West wasn't Oh Paul
Wellstone what were Paul Wellstone was
murdered in 2002 because he opposed the
Iraq war and allegedly because he wanted
to investigate 9/11 he was a US senator
he was the leading left-leaning Democrat
in the US Senate and his name again is
all Wellstone yeah one week before he
died he was running for re-election Dick
Cheney had personally targeted him and
said you know we are gonna take
Wellstone out of the Senate one way or
another and then one week before he died
well as Cheney threatened Wellstone
saying that if you continue with your
obstructionism there will be the most
severe possible consequences to the
state of Minnesota and to you personally
then one week later wellstones plane was
taken down he his wife and his daughter
all died along with it his campaign
staff they all died in that plane crash
and there's all sorts of evidence that
that plane crash was taking it happened
through an EMF weapon and for the
details you can google the film
Wellstone they killed him but that's a
film out there yeah well and there's a
book called American assassination the
strange death of Paul Wellstone written
by two professors for arrows and Jim
Fetzer let me get your reaction to this
so there are all kinds of reasons we
thought we were set up to fail we got
started late we had a very short time
free indeed we had to get it extended we
did not have enough money they were
faith they were afraid we were going to
hang somebody that would point the
finger Lee and I write in our book that
we think the Commission in many ways was
set up to fail because we had not enough
money we didn't have enough time we had
been appointed by the most partisan
people in Washington who are these guys
are they that they were the ones who are
running the